thanks me how good morning everybody so
this talk is about a bunch of things but
in particular is about large and small
markets and comparisons between them so
what do I mean by large and small
markets large and small markets okay I
talk about large markets I'm thinking
about sort of a you know classic
economic sense of large markets ok I
think about some scenario I have lots of
goods to sell I have lots of buyers who
want to buy those goods buyers don't
have market power right demand is very
predictable everything's very smooth all
right and conventional wisdom is that if
I'm in that sort of scenario and i'm
trying to sell all these goods all right
i try to sell them in sort of an
efficient way it's very reasonable thing
for me to do to just post some prices
right and let's sort of you know
competitive equilibrium sort of do the
job for me all right and I could find
prices that sort of clear my market
efficiently on the other hand I could
think about small markets where I'm
trying to sell some you know small
number of goods these goods are maybe
rare or you know unpredictable in their
demand i have a small pool of buyers who
interested in buying them in this sort
of scenario you know conventional wisdom
is why i should run an auction okay
which is you know more annoying and
costly and centralized to run all right
but the fact that maybe I'm going to be
guaranteed you know efficient CX post
right even though my domain is
unpredictable it makes it worth the
effort for me to go through this okay so
we have this sort of mapping between
sort of classic scenarios and what we
should do all right what makes our lives
interesting right people in this room is
that the sorts of scenarios we think
about in a GT some fall somewhere
between these two scenarios right we
typically work in regimes where our
markets are large enough right that
computation is a thing and so I can't
necessarily design some oxygen which
guarantees and the efficiency but at the
same time there's enough structure in my
market right that I can't just you know
imagine that invisible hands are going
to solve all my problems for me all
right there's something
to do okay and it's in the spirit of the
sort of this gray area between these two
extremes they want to give this talk ok
I want to think about the way that
theory from either side can inform each
other all right and that when I analyze
sort of typical agt problems I want to
think about you know both types of
analysis simultaneously all right and
what I want to do is I want to try to
make that connection explicit I want to
say that in a lot of the source of
problems that we think about all right
both of these perspectives are relevant
and so I want to you know invert this
mapping a little bit I want to talk
about how if I want to design mechanisms
for small markets all right it's
reasonable for me to you know post
prices and give up on you know even
though I can't necessarily find
efficient prices and then in fact the
problem of designing good prices can be
informed by sort of the classic you know
smoothness price of Anarchy mechanism
design results that we think about you
know every day and then in the large
market scenario I want to do the same
thing I want to think about auctions all
right smooth price of Anarchy sorts of
results that we sort of classically
think about for worst-case instances and
I want to talk about how those price of
Anarchy results can tailor themselves to
large market scenarios in which we
expect you know efficiency should be
easier to obtain okay so I want to think
about getting efficiency results through
something like a smoothness framework
that as my input instances become large
and more friendly to efficient analysis
those results my bounds will actually
get better and better okay and I want to
do this through thinking about price
taking behavior all right so this is
about price taking behavior and worst
case efficiency bounds informing each
other okay so small markets large
markets that's the plan for the talk I'm
going to start with small
so the running example through the both
parts of this talk is going to be
comment or election problems we've heard
a lot about cognate oral action problems
the last couple days so and many of us
are very familiar I want to just go
through this very quickly just to make
sure we're all on the same page I
imagine a model in which I have a single
seller the seller has a bunch of
heterogeneous goods to sell I have a
bunch of buyers the buyers are also
heterogeneous they have you know
valuation functions that map sets of
goods that they go home that the value
and they enjoy if they get those goods
for this part of the talk i'm going to
focus on sub modular or more generally
fractionally sub additive valuation
functions I want to consider a beige in
setting right values like agents types
are being drawn independently from some
valuation functions and agents have
quasi-linear preferences and my goal is
sort of the designer of my market is to
you know allocate goods efficiently okay
so super well study problem a little bit
of background one of the reasons why
this problem is you know an example that
I'd like to you know use to exemplify
this this perspective is that it has
this you know sort of juicy gap here in
that you know if I'm only considering
the algorithmic version of this
optimization problem right the
optimization problem in which this
market problem is building built upon
you can get a constant approximation all
right but if I wanted to design a
dominant strategy instead of
incompatible mechanism okay we know how
to get the poly logarithmic gap a
Polliwog romantic approximation but it's
not currently known how to if we can get
a constant approximation here given
access to say demand queries okay but on
the other hand if we give up on
incentive compatibility and say design
some markets such as it has you know
good performance at equilibrium well
then we know how to do that right for
example you could run simultaneous first
price auctions and you get an
approximation factor at equilibrium that
matches that of like this first best
algorithmic solution
the only thing we had to give up on here
what's not my strategy and center
compatibility so what I want to do is
try to get dominus regit Senate
credibility back all right so I want to
present to you is a mechanism that is
dominant strategy incentive compatible
gets the constant approximation but in
the Beijing sense okay so whereas this
sort of mechanism is not incentive
compatible but spryer free I want to use
priors and I want to use the fact that
i'm getting measuring performance and
expectation and get a constant
approximation in a dominant strategy and
send a compatible way and moreover the
meccans I'm going to present here is of
a very simple form right as I mentioned
in the beginning I want to use posted
prices all right I want to use pricing
to solve this sort of small arbitrary
market problem okay so what do I mean by
posted price mechanism I mean you know
sequential posted pricing is sort of the
standard way okay let me just illustrate
that I mean that my mechanism designer
is going to look at the priors it's
going to look at the information he has
available to him he's going to come up
with some prices he's going to put those
prices on the items for sale then the
buyers are going to come into the market
one by one they're going to see their
realize types and they're going to ask
they're going to look at the prices on
the items and figure out what items they
want most at those prices okay so
utility is going to be quasi-linear and
additive across items in terms of price
ok so maybe player one comes in and they
say well at these prices I'd like these
two items so we'll take them and go home
your player 2 comes in and says well
alright I would have really liked item
to but I don't who's gone so I can't
take it anymore all right so maybe
player 2 goes home empty-handed player 3
comes in and says oh well I'd like
player item 3 item am I guess here and
takes it home okay that's the engine all
right so this is the mechanism this is
how it works the main thing to do is to
figure out what these item prices should
be all right that's
game okay given some item prices i have
this mechanism this mechanism has a
bunch of properties it's obviously
strategy proof yesterday I had
quotations around obviously and now I
can take them away Thank You shang wu i
want to point out that i don't care
about the arrival order of the bidders
it can be arbitrary i don't care about
the way they break ties if they're
indifferent between multiple bundles
that can also be arbitrary i also want
to point out that Maxum equis and the
prices are static I'm not updating the
prices over time I'm picking the prices
at step zero and then they're just
staying there forever this is very
related to a literature in revenue
maximization that uses precisely
mechanisms of this form what we're doing
is we're taking this ID and we're
applying it to welfare maximization now
so okay good I want to say that what
we're doing is we're getting a constant
approximation of the optimal expected
welfare in a prior dependent manner
using posted price mechanisms and the
main reason why I'm wanting to describe
this work in a talk on large and small
markets is that the way in which I'm
going to compute these prices is going
to be very heavily informed by an
existing approach which is this one all
right I want to argue that you can
basically read off the prices that you
should use by peeking into smoothness
proofs right that give us price of
Anarchy results right in non incentive
compatible mechanisms okay so let me
explain how we do that I'm going to
first go through the smoothness argument
now I know a lot of people in this room
have seen this argument many times also
Tim grave a great overview of this
argument in the boot camp but I'm going
to refer to ideas in this proof quite a
bit so I just bear with me i'm going to
go through pretty quickly okay so we can
get a 1 minus 1 over e i'm going to go
through a simple argument that gets you
half okay i want to argue that you get
half of the efficient welfare at any
base and actually cool
priyam of a simultaneous first price
auction all right so this is the auction
where agents submit independent bids on
all the items and each item is resolved
in a first price auction okay so why is
that well just smoothing this argument
okay smoothness argument goes the
following way my claim is about based
nash equilibrium but for now let's think
of just fixing a particular type profile
right fix a type profile suppose that in
that type profile agent I should win I
should mention that this argument I'm
going to restrict myself to the single
item case right very nice composition
results Ava and vasilis who's somewhere
yeah it's going to give me the result
that I claim right but all of the core
idea that I'm going to be interested in
is going to character it in single item
case so single item case i can just read
off who the winner should be okay and
then I imagine that at whatever
equilibrium that I'm considering the
bids that occur is you know be for this
particular type profile v okay so I is
the social planner would like agent I to
win maybe he wins and maybe he doesn't
so I want to imagine you know I want to
ask player I you know why didn't you win
and in particular I might say well
here's a bid you could have made why
didn't you make this bid well I says
okay well um he says well that's an
interesting idea what utility would I
get at that bid and there's a very
simple case analysis I claim that this
inequality holds why is that well either
the player wins at price VI over to vi
over to in which case his utility is VI
minus V I over 2 which is this and so
it's certainly bigger than this minus
something maybe he loses at that bid but
if he loses at that bid that means
someone else bid higher which means that
this is negative right the maximum bit
of anyone else is higher so this is
negative which is certainly bigger than
the 0 which he gets because he doesn't
win okay so you've an inequality like
this that holds this is a smoothness
type inequality if you sum all over all
the players
now this is only for a fixed valuation
profile but I can basically take
expectations now if i take expectations
this I becomes a random variable so I
have to be a little bit careful but if
I'm sufficiently careful this argument
passes through expectations and getting
an equality like this it might take
revenue to the other side to get
precisely that the welfare to
equilibrium is at least half the optimal
welfare in expectation okay so that's
the argument okay why did I take you
through that I want to point something
out which is that this reasoning here is
essentially reasoning against a fixed
price okay player I is saying he has
this number in his head which is VI over
2 and he says well if I could acquire
the item at price VI over 2 i'm happy i
get utility VI over to if I can't
acquire it a VI of to maybe someone else
purchased it at that price not very
happy but someone else at least was
willing to pay that okay so i could
charge the welfare loss to that person
who is willing to pay this amount all
right so I want to imagine that I could
take this argument and if the designer
could figure out what this VI over to
was and just post that as a price on the
item the same analysis would just go
through all right and I'd get a welfare
bound on on whoever purchases now the
problem is I can't post this price
because I don't know the type of agent I
all right but I just sort of wave my
hands to the claim which is that this
argument passes through expectations and
we know what this is if we know the
priors we know what half the expected
optimal value is so we could post that
price and then just taking expectations
I should get a similar welfare bound ok
this is exactly what we do ok so just to
make sure everyone's with me I want to
go through a really quick example okay
if I had one item for sale two bidders
values uniform 01 I expected up in what
social welfare is expected max which is
two-thirds what I'm suggesting is if I
wanted to implement to posted price
mechanism for this problem I should just
post half of opt which is at one-third
and what would happen in my posted price
mechanism if I did that well the welfare
i get is just the probability someone
buys at this price times the expected
value of someone who purchase is subject
to them purchasing well this is just one
minus a ninth all right 1 minus the
third time's a third times the expected
value of someone conditional on being
bigger in the third which is two thirds
which is 16 2016 20 sevenths which is a
little bit less than two thirds okay and
indeed so we're in a small market
setting we shouldn't expect posted
prices to obtain efficient outcomes
there are some efficiency loss here but
it's not too much of a loss okay so the
question is how much loss is there how
efficient is it to use this approach and
there's open our paper is that it's
actually not too inefficient all right
if I take a sub modular counter auction
or more generally fractionally civ
additive then I can find these prices
and they're in G just for those you
familiar with the smoothness argument
there just the prices that you would
read off from the smoothness argument
such at the expected social welfare for
gram I posted price mechanism is half of
the expected optimal welfare now those
of you familiar with property qualities
might have noticed that that argument i
just gave on the previous slide is
precisely an invocation of profit
inequality and indeed the single item
version of this is just a restatement of
profit inequality so you can rephrase
what I just said as like a multi-item
extension of profit inequalities this is
basically what we're doing yeah folk of
having a composition to your own
sort of a plan I would say there is hope
yes I do i do not have a general result
of that form we're working on it now i
framed all this originally in terms of
designing incentive compatible
mechanisms right and so the previous
result was just existential I didn't
actually show you how to compute those
prices it turns out the Third's you can
have a computational version of this
result and it's a black box form suppose
that I have some sort of a comet or
auction I have some allocation algorithm
for that auction problem and suppose I
have sample access to these
distributions then i can compute prices
in polynomial time by which I mean
polynomial in N and M such that I get
half of the expected welfare of this
original algorithm okay minus some term
which is going to be due to sampling
so as a corollary if you plug in your
favorite approximation algorithm for sub
modular come to options you get a
constant approximation Dominus Writing
Center pedal mechanism now if I wanted
to implement this in a direct revelation
way I need to be able to simulate the
bidders coming in and picking their most
demanded bundles which means i need to
manned queries alright so if i wanted to
think about this in terms of like
dominant like direct revelation
mechanisms this is subject to the
availability of demand queries okay so
let me just you know say another like
just one or two more words about exactly
how these prices are picked just to make
sure we're on the same page all right if
I was in say a unit demand setting all
right which is like one step up from
single item then the way I pick my
prices as I say well imagine drawing a
valuation from this valuation profile
from these distributions work out what
the optimal allocation would be and see
what's the value that a certain item is
contributing to the social welfare under
that optimal allocation and this is like
an instantiation of what we think the
price should be scaled down by half the
price I said is just the expectation of
this that's like in some sense the right
price to put right and basically our
claim is that these prices generate half
the optimal welfare and the way to get
the algorithmic result right the main
reason I wrote this down was to say the
algorithmic result is actually not much
more complicated because I didn't
actually use anywhere that this was the
optimal allocation so I could just plug
in any allocation here alright take any
allocation and look at what contribution
each item is contributing under that
allocation and the only thing left to do
is to actually work out what this
expectation is now the the distribution
over evaluation functions could be quite
large you could have a very high support
I don't want my running time to depend
on the support size of those
distributions but we can estimate the
value of this by sampling and that's why
we get our sampling error
okay so I mentioned that this analysis
basically went through smoothness you
could hope to apply this argument to
other smooth mechanisms as well ND you
can so for example i can extend beyond
xos valuations to valuations with
bounded compliments all right using with
this mph k hierarchy for example and I
get a posted price mechanism that gets
an approximation factor that decays with
the extent of compliments for other
sorts of smooth that's our results you
might know things like greedy algorithms
optimization subject to make Troy
constraints and so on you can get
similar sorts of bounds all right this
is ongoing work that includes issue
original authors Thomas and Paul do I
want to point out that while in these
cases I could just fix my prices at the
beginning all right and not change them
once I go into more interesting
constraints applying a similar reasoning
actually results in prices that might
change over time okay so there's a power
to having dynamic prices okay um so just
before moving on to the next part of the
talk I want to just you know
re-emphasize that what this was
basically was a bridging of sort of
price theory and sort of the smoothness
bounds that we've spent a lot of time
thinking about recently and basically
what this is is showing way the you know
I have a smooth mechanism which is prior
independent and gets me performance in
equilibrium I can in some scenarios give
up prior independence and gain
demonstrating Center credibility and I
want to note that because of the fact
that this analysis was robust to things
like tiebreaking this these sorts of
mechanisms can be interesting even in
scenarios where competitive equilibria
toots valuations for example we know
that there exist posted prices that
generate efficient outcomes but that's
those results tend to be delicate with
respect to tie breaking all right and so
in some sense this is a slightly robust
version of competitive equilibrium
alisis that
gives up on full efficiency okay i want
move on to the large
so this result i just presented I think
falls within sort of a growing space of
literature within out of the game theory
in which we're presented with some
market design problem built on top of an
optimization problem that we find
difficult to solve in a computational
way and so we have some first best
algorithmic solution that we know and
our goal is designed a market right that
matches are almost matches that sort of
threshold designed by what like a
computationally bounded social planner
could do right and there's been a lot of
success stories in recent years in which
we can get pretty close to the bounds
that that we know and love when I talked
to Mike honest friends about these sorts
of results they say okay that's that's
nice that's great but there's a
criticism that tends to come up this is
Don Quixote attacking windmills because
they might be giants and and this story
of Don Quixote running into a field
seeing these windmills ensuing that
they're an adversary a giant and wanting
to attack them stands in place of a
warning to not necessarily over exert
oneself against adversaries that may or
may not be there right now in
theoretical computer science we have
sort of an ongoing quest to attack
worst-case instances this has led us to
a lot of beautiful theory and a lot of
great insights and a lot of you know new
mechanisms but I think in that a lot of
the scenarios that we care about sort of
fall in this space between small
worst-case instances markets and large
well-behaved markets it's important for
us to think about leveraging that nice
structure when we're designing and
comparing mechanisms okay when we're
designing a mechanism for say an
advertising auction right the form of
Jason was talking about yesterday or any
sort of scenario in which i'm selling
lots and lots of things to law
and lots of people over and over again
we can think about worst-case instances
all right and design and compare
mechanisms for sort of the worst-case
bounds but in many cases sort of the
scenario wherein is more closer to the
large market world in which I have lots
of randomness that's due to for example
noise introduced by the assignment
algorithms that are actually designing
these instances for me and individuals
are not necessarily strategizing over
the individual auctions but sort of an
aggregate okay this starts looking more
and more like a large market setting but
not necessarily all the way to the
extreme where we can analyze this thing
in like the limit game where everyone's
continuous and convex because there's
still sort of algorithmic problems to
solve and so I'd like when designing
some algorithmic solution to be able to
compare and generate bounds for it not
just for these worst-case instances but
in a way that demonstrates how well this
thing will work as my market grows large
okay so the goal of this part of the
talk is a framework for doing this okay
I'd like to have something like in the
spirit of smooth analysis that gives me
some framework for studying large
classes of games that tells me if I have
a sequence of games that seems to be
getting nicer and nicer larger and
larger say you know do my bounds improve
and if so at what rates and I'd like to
be able to differentiate different
mechanisms in different markets and
different scenarios based on how well
they do sort of in this large limit
a huge space of related work on this
this is a laughably small cross section
basically I want to point out that the
analysis of large games and large
auctions and markets in particular is
extremely well studied through a lot of
different perspectives mean field
analysis differential privacy convexity
in the limit for the most part this line
of what this line of work is doing is
saying take a large finite game i can
approximate it by some smooth nice limit
game I didn't mean smooth in terms of
the smoothness learn I mean some of the
terms of like a nice large game and i
can analyze an equilibrium in the nice
large game and then argue that well the
large finite games are close enough to
the limit game that maybe i can just
imagine that people will play the limit
equilibria all right and so I'll relax
the solution concept and then get a
claim that you get efficiency in the
limit and what I'm proposing is in some
sense the opposite in which I want to
look at actual equilibria of a sequence
of games and I want to understand how
their performance changes as the game
gets larger and larger all right and so
in some sense i find this complementary
sort of this space of results so large
markets tend to be efficient in the
limit we know small markets can be
inefficient and this recent line of work
in our firm exome design is basically
telling us it can't be too inefficient
right we know that in worst-case small
instances we get half quarter log what
have you okay and so in some sense i'm
trying to bridge the gap between these
two extremes so what do we do i'm going
to present a notion of smoothness that
gives you a sufficient condition for
near optimality in sort of large games i
want to present a particular way to use
that framework all right i'm going to
suggest is
useful in these scenarios we apply this
to a bunch of different games right just
sort of show its applicability and in
keeping with the theme of the talk i'm
going to mostly concentrate on the first
one which is analyzing simultaneous
options so again come torial options
this is exactly the same framework as
before with one minor change to I guess
actually it'll be convenient for me to
think about there being multiple copies
of a fixed number of types of goods all
right so I want to think about there now
being a bunch of types of goods and
there's a certain number of copies of
each type and I'm no longer going to be
restricting my attention to some modular
xos valuation function so I want to
think about like arbitrary valuation
functions over goods okay here is in a
picture so now that I have multiple
copies of types of goods i want to be a
little bit more precise about what i
mean by a simultaneous uniform price
auction I mean the following here's one
particular good say IJ players are going
to place bids on that good and what
they're going to do is they're going to
play sort of marginal bits alright so
this player is going to say place a
sequence of bids and want to interpret
those bids as the marginal value that
you would that person would pay for one
extra copy of the good alright so they
would pay for for one copy to for
another copy one for the third copy now
of course the valuation that the player
actually enjoys from these goods depends
maybe on what other goods they get all
right perspective of this auction
they're going to resolve each item sort
of independently of everything else so
what players do is they submit these
bids the max is going to sort the bids
and just allocate as many goods as it
has to the highest bids and then i'm
going to set a price equal to the
highest losing bid
right this is like the so that has a
second price type of flavor so if I want
to analyze this auction say in small
markets I apply say smooth this
framework right this is sort of a
smoothness inequality in words but what
I want to do in this talk is think about
a variant of this analysis or look at a
sequence of auctions growing in this
case growing with respect to the number
of bidders and ask about how its
smoothness properties change as the
number of bidders grows large all right
so smoothness the normal form gives
worst case bounds I want to give sort of
a large market version of it which gives
efficiency balance in the limit and for
large finite n so now I've gotten to the
point where I have to actually write
down the smooth this condition so let me
draw it actually pictographic lee yeah
so I'm being intentionally ambiguous
because large is going to sort of depend
on the context so what I mean here is
that I have a sequence of games that are
getting nice in some way and I'm
indifferent to the parameter under which
like what it is about the auctions
that's getting nicer over time now in
this particular setting what I'm going
to mean by large is the number of
players is getting large is growing the
number of copies of each good is growing
and there's some noise in the system
that I'm going to quantify but I think
of that as a specific instantiation and
so like at this point I'm sort of being
I'm extracting away from that and saying
if you had some sequence of games that
had some property that was causing its
smoothness bounce to get better and
better as I go along the sequence then
I'm going to have some framework to
think about that but so let me let me go
a couple slides and then I'll pin down
for this exact particular example what i
mean by large
okay so okay quick recap what is regular
smoothness mean I have this auction that
I have in mind I imagine that there are
some bids that would result in the
optimal allocation being done thank you
and I have some bids that I think of as
being an equilibrium of this game I
think of each player I deviating to the
optimal allocation to unilaterally
deviating to his piece of this optimal
allocation evaluate a bid profile and I
say the mechanism is smooth if there
exists deviations there exists an
optimal sequence a sequence of bids of
this form
such that the sum of the utilities under
these unilateral deviations can be
bounded by some parameter times the
optimal welfare minus some parameter
times the revenue obtained by the
mechanism in this original equilibrium
okay so this is a framing of smoothness
that's tailored to auctions okay the
sort of the classic theorem in the space
is that if your auction is smooth then
it has bounded price of Anarchy right
its efficiency at equilibrium is bounded
so what are we contributing so the first
constitution is in some sense trivial
I'm going to say that which it's a
definition I'm going to take a sequence
of auctions all right and again I'm not
really saying anything about what it is
that's growing as this in this parameter
which is going up and I'm going to say
that the sequence is smooth in the large
if basically in words each of the
individual auctions is smooth under some
parameters that are converging in a
particular way to lambda mu all right
now precisely it'll be convenient for me
to think of the lambda as being the
thing that's converging okay so I'll say
that for each n right if I go large if I
go large enough then each of these
options from that point onward is going
to be smooth under parameters lambda 1
minus epsilon then mu okay fine so
basically what I'm saying is I have a
sequence of auctions each option is
smooth and the smoothness parameters are
getting better over time right that's
basically this definition now i'm
presenting it um oh sorry you're right
I'm not its I'm not claiming that it's
necessarily getting better over time I'm
saying that it's converging in the sense
that you know as I go as long as I go
far enough I'm gonna get close to lambda
mu yeah thanks thank you
in particular it's quite likely that i'm
not getting better over time and I'm
bouncing around okay so fine so if i
have this then i could take my price of
anak analysis sort of through the limit
and argue that sort of in the limit as I
go down these games I get a converged to
a price of Anarchy bound which is
bounded by lambda mu fine okay why am i
presenting this I want to argue there's
a particular way to use this which is
going to be quite useful okay so I want
to imagine that to establish these
smoothness pounds i'm not going to
analyze each game individually rather
i'm going to think of each agent as
thinking about some limit game some sort
of nice game that's very smooth more
smooth than the individual games I don't
think of this like a delusional game and
I want this delusional game to
approximate the real games in the sense
that sort of the difference in the
utilities that the players enjoy is
vanishing as I go along the sequence
okay so each player has in mind some
sort of limit nice game and the amount
that the players are deluding themselves
by thinking they're playing the smooth
game is going down as the game goes
large okay so here's that just written
down in in math all right I have some
delusional utility that's not too far
from the real utility and I have a
smoothness condition that's with respect
to this delusion as opposed to with
respect to the original game all right
now I want to point out that I'm written
as smoothness condition in particular
way I want that the utilities that the
players think they're going to obtain
under the delusion is bounded by the
welfare and the revenue with respect to
the true game
and basically theorem is that if you
satisfy these conditions then you're
smooth in the large right and moreover
you can bound the rate of convergence to
this limit by these errors in precisely
how these approximations work Thanks
okay so now what do I mean by large in
this particular example let's go through
an example of this I have bidders I have
items I want to imagine that I have a
number of copies of the items which is
growing with the number of bidders I'm
going to say for this example that
they're growing linearly we don't
actually necessarily need this in all
cases but it'll make life easier for us
there's a constant number of types of
goods I want to think of the players
values as being bounded away from 0 all
right i want to say each player wants a
fixed constant number of goods of each
type of good at most all right so mark
individual buyers market power is
shrinking as the games go large and i
also want to introduce some noise in the
sense that when buyers arrive to the
market there's not precise certainty
about who's going to be there all right
there's some small probability that a
particular buyer is going to not show up
all right this is a particular way to
set up what I mean by a large market I'm
not want to say that it's the one true
way but here's a particular example of
what I might mean by a large market and
what I want to show is that under this
way of defining large market I get
efficiency in the large so let me say
that again I have simultaneous item
auctions I evaluations that are
arbitrary right arbitrary compliments or
whatnot in the small this is can be
quite inefficient but in this large
market limit I actually get full
efficiency okay and we get a certain
convergence rate on this okay and how do
we do this oh I'm starting to get tight
on time so I'll do this reasonably
quickly but basically what we do is we
just say each buyer is going to imagine
they have no market power right let's
say that the buyers arrive they see what
the other buyers are doing from which
they estimate that if they didn't
participate there'd be certain prices at
which the items clear
and he'll just imagine that they could
purchase goods at those prices they'll
imagine that if they arrived right a
buyer comes in and makes a bid of you
know 10 that they get this good at value
to as opposed to value 3 which is what
would happen in the real market all
right that's the delusion
and basically we just have to argue that
this approximates the real outcomes of
the game in the large limit and that
it's quite smooth now the fact that it
approximates in the large limit comes
from the randomness in arrivals okay if
a player comes in and this is what the
world looks like and this red player
says I want three units and these are my
bids he's really far off in his
prediction of what his utility is going
to be right he thinks that he's going to
get them at a very low price in fact he
only wins to them an extremely high
price but if players are not arriving
with some fixed probability then the
effect of this getting the fixed point
wrong gets diluted okay there's sort of
a random price anyway and we're only
nudging that distribution a little bit
that's how the approximation works to
get smoothness we basically just want to
appeal to first welfare type theorems
right if each player thinks that they're
just facing a fixed vector of prices all
right and we ask them you know what
would be efficient like what would be
your equilibrium if you're facing fixed
prices well it's is similar to an
analysis of competitive equilibrium we
sort of know that players should
basically behave efficiently and go
after their optimal sets now there are
some caveats to making that analysis
work because of the random it's in the
system but in the same way that
algorithms go from efficient sorry the
smoothness analysis passes into the
Beijing limit you can make this analysis
work here okay so if you go through that
you get a smoothness type bound like
this the only little caveat is that the
revenue bounds are with respect to this
delusional revenue we want the real
revenue but because the players are only
under estimating prices in fact the
inequality goes the right way right so
if i replace the delusional revenue with
the real revenue it's only higher and so
this inequality only holds more tightly
more generally okay so we get exactly a
smoothness head condition and we're done
okay so that's how you get this result
okay I just want to say one more thing
and I'm done I could imagine running the
same algorithm on the same analysis on
say greedy come torial auctions
right imagine a world in which i'm not
selling items individually people want
bundles of goods ok and then and they
make package bids and I i allocate these
package bids you know from highest bid
to lowest all right I could imagine
running an auction like this
you could go through the same analysis
and you get some improvement in the
limit but not very much you can argue
that in the limit if you take sort of
the an appropriate definition of large
market you don't get full efficiency you
get price of energy d which is very
similar to what happens in the small
market limit right so the comparison i
want to make here is that in the small
right in the worst case both
simultaneous item auctions and greedy
auctions get like an order d
approximation okay if people want
bundles of size d but simultaneous I'm
options go to efficiency in the limit
and greedy auctions don't okay and so
this you know I'm what I'm doing is I'm
hoping to provide a bit of information
about how to disentangle and compare
these mechanisms it is not necessarily
immediately apparent from looking at the
worst-case instance in the paper we look
at more results but I think that I am
out of time so I'll stop there thank you
very much
secondly father's nice and reminds me of
the kind of results we have economical
competitive computer games or just
completed limiters also set up some game
and the limit approximator so the
question is what kind of games doesn't
work for example for the work for first
prize o trong game or is it the only
angle game or is it works so you're
asking to what extent does this analysis
extend into like other types of options
like first price and not sure so in some
sense we set up this framework with the
as leggins generally as possible to
apply to other settings now in this
paper we don't necessarily don't
directly analyze simultaneous first
price off the top of my head I don't see
a barrier to it passing through there
but I mean in some sense the one of the
things about this framework that I'd
hope to convince you of is that it
wouldn't necessarily give the same
answer in all sort of markets and so
maybe I can frame a reasonable notion of
large market first Christ auctions in
which I don't get convergys the limit
and hopefully I'd learn something from
that so come on combine the two parts of
your talk and in the seconds flat
whatever the assumption was for this
madness here for prices so that the
price taking behavior is so those prices
are essentially optimal or
great question I believe the answer is
yes I'm not at the point where I can
state definitively the answer is yes
there yeah but they're working on it
there's a slight barrier to that that
needs to be overcome but you're right
it's reasonable to expect that might be
true can you give some intuition if I
have like a heavy tail distribution of
evaluations how does this work to them
then so maybe the delusional
approximation isn't so good in that case
right absolutely so the that convergence
rate the one over square root n is sort
of being driven by the rate at which
these prices converge you know as your
market gets larger and larger and you
can certainly set up scenarios in which
that convergence as much slower or maybe
doesn't even happen at all right and so
certainly I expect you can set up
scenarios in which you don't get
efficiency in the limit using the sort
of analysis and some sense I'm hoping
that you know this somehow disentangle
is like if I have a large market where
the distributions ever super heavy tail
maybe it's not actually that large right
like a dawqq shins might be an example
in which even though there's lots of
participants a lot of my revenue is
coming from the tail and so it acts more
like a small market
you